Bonjour Vanessa
O
Poussin j'ai fait bouger l'animal brut
incarné dans la justice si tu t'attends à me voir
Je vais arrêter avec ce sont les
principaux conflits moins c'est que
vous savez que vous savez que ceux-ci accompliront cela pour
Globo pas en tant que complice
va conquérir Thunder en tant que complice
quelqu'un qui m'accompagne
non mais c'est mieux Messi ou toi Johnny
Johnny Johnny vois ne peut en choisir qu'un
C'est
a peut quitter les zones à risque je vais
Johnny demande de fuir le premier samba
bien sûr moelleux qui s'avère populaire mais c'est pour
un médecin enlève le Bayern pour Juninho
coule sur le juge supérieur
de la Justice en inscrivent d'autres
quoi
ne sois pas sexuel
en tant que complices
complices
sur une
chéri johnny somberland jones va bien
mieux que d'être premier état Rubio
Seigneur soit avec toi commence et va
voir tout Juninho est meilleur Richard Gere
pour Renault déjà lié au côté a
sac et pour connaître les problèmes que je
J'ai mieux entendu crier aux gardes
mais il n'y a aucun de nous
se conformer à ce Globo pas en tant que complice
Vous savez que tant que complices
complices
ET là